hi I'm Adam Rogers here for National
geekdad Day to talk about the little
bits set of circuitry it's a fun kit
it's a little bit like Legos for
circuits it has a battery that's a power
source and some wires and it teaches you
how to put together a circuit so instead
of using a you know a soldering gun
those kind of connections what you do is
have these little magnetic connections
at the end of each of these pieces so
just as an example battery wire power
input and then you can just do something
easy like the magnet will connect to a
which one is that the light I think yeah
so it's just a little LED right and and
they're set up so that they'll only
connect in the right direction so if you
try to build the circuit wrong it won't
stick together you build it right well
so that's the basic thing but here's the
cool part and I actually tried this with
my my seven-year-old son at home and he
figured this out more quickly than I did
is that the the green pieces are kind of
or what they call outputs for the set
what they really mean by that is the
green pieces will do something if you
throw power into it there's lights and
there's a couple other things I'll show
you in a minute but the pink ones they
call inputs and these are sort of like
gates that'll change how much power is
getting through in the circuit so just
as an example here's a dimmer switch a
rheostat and let's see all right so I
got that one plugged in now this is
gonna regulate how much power is getting
from the little 9-volt battery which I
did not put on my tongue and then if you
get the LED again so now if I turn that
if I built this right yeah so the amount
of light getting through will change and
what you can really tell is instead of
using the single LED there's a power
monitor piece so it'll show how much
power is going through and that you know
I suppose you could go to RadioShack and
buy the parts that would let you do that
but I would not know how to put those
together with this it's all set up so it
goes together by itself so this is the
thing that my son liked the best
he took the button and then a little
vibrating motor
and kept wanting to put it on my arm and
like so he pushed the little motor onto
my arm and then like try to sneak it as
if I didn't know he had just built a
giant circuit next to me now I don't
know how much he actually learned about
how to build a circuit but he definitely
liked being able to make something
happen he loved the idea of being able
to put something together and see action
at the other end and if he was able to
put together a little Christmas tree
looking light at just seven I can only
imagine what he'll be able to set on
fire when he's 12